[Music]
when I was researching my book the
future of humanity I came across a
comment made by Thomas Jefferson Thomas
Jefferson made the biggest the biggest
gamble of his life buying the Louisiana
Purchase from Napoleon Napoleon was
fighting the British he needed a card
cash immediately he had Louisiana and
that whole mid middle portion of the
United States and so Napoleon sold it to
Thomas Jefferson for a song but how much
ever since thought how long would it
take to investigate what he had just
purchased he had doubled the size of the
USA think about that and he probably
violated the Constitution in the process
everyone forgets that everyone glosses
over that fact but hey when Lewis and
Clark went into into the torrid
territories that compromised the
Louisiana Purchase
they found tremendous prospects for
wealth and prosperity but Thomas
Jefferson wrote that it may take a
thousand years a thousand years before
they can then begin to settle the West
well how long did it take a few decades
because what happened
gold gold was discovered in California
sparking the gold rush and within just a
few years millions millions of
prospectors settlers fortune hunters
converged on California it didn't take a
thousand years to develop that then the
question now is is there going to be a
new Gold Rush in outer space some people
think so some Google billionaires have
created an organization a company
planetary resources that are looking
into prospecting in the asteroid belt
now asteroids come in all shapes and
sizes and we're cataloguing them now and
we have already found some prospective
asteroids that could be mine one
asteroid perhaps maybe 30 50 feet across
brought back down either to the moon or
to the planet Earth could in fact yield
billions billions of dollars in we
Ward's because of the rare earths and
the platinum type metals that you find
inside you see the electronics industry
is dependent upon rare earths where are
these where earth elements found mainly
in China they're everywhere of course
but China has the most developed market
and the Chinese in turn supply on the
order of 90% of the rare earths well a
few years ago they decided to capitalize
that and raise the price
all of a sudden shockwaves shockwaves
spread around the earth because people
realize that oh my god
China has a stranglehold a stranglehold
on high-technology how can you build the
next iPhone if you don't have the rare
earths to to make the transistors and to
make the delicate components of these
high-tech devices so I think what's
happening here is that some people see
an area for profit and that is asteroid
mining now of course the infrastructure
for that doesn't exist but NASA has
looked at its budget and does have a
program that has been shelved
temporarily to call to redirect an
asteroid the asteroid redirect program
is to send the SLS booster rocket into
outer space with the Orion capsule
it will then intercept an asteroid and
bring it back to orbit around the moon
then it could be mined as it orbits
around the moon or as its brought back
to the planet Earth and so this is now
beyond the phase of science fiction
we're no longer talking about dreaming
about an asteroid redirect we're talking
about an actual plan with the economics
with the details laid out however at the
present time we have to wait for NASA's
SLS rocket to mature to the point where
we can intercept an asteroid
[Music]